you know what I didn't like about Batman
which one the newest one oh how did you
tell you about the back the guy from
Twilight no Robert yeah yeah yeah yeah
um what I didn't like about it is you
know when the Riddler did you see it I
saw half of it because I got bored
quickly
I just couldn't tell I was like what is
this what are we doing
like Lisa Traeger has a joke she's like
it's 70 years of Batman like it's just
enough like yeah you know and I agree
with her I'm like every time they're
like a new Batman movie I'm like we get
it he's mad his parents are dead he's
very rich and he lives I don't know what
else let me say like this time yeah the
only good Batman is the one with Uma
Thurman and Arnold Schwarzenegger
because it's schlock and shitty and it's
like this is really kind of what Batman
should be the Joel Schubach
okay okay just giving that man movies
more money I can't get a special but
Joel Schumacher is [__] up at the box
office and wasted billions of dollars
like more yeah well um I'm gonna finish
my thought then sorry it's okay okay so
you didn't like it but um I was
re-watching it the other day got it
bored I've seen it 40 times okay and um
it's my one of my favorites and um the
newest the newest one is one I just like
the Jean like I just like that genre I
mean that type of that Superhero
specifically is that something straight
guys relate to like this sort of like
mysteriousness of like the bachelor life
I don't know what it is about fat like I
could give two shits about Batman I'll
tell you why I think Batman is popular
yeah he doesn't he's just a regular dude
he doesn't have any power not that
regular but he's not he's no it really
doesn't have like Powers Flames out of
his eyeballs and like but that might
have went out of his butthole that makes
him boring right what that makes him
more boring okay you don't really fly
who's making these Contraptions
either but he has billions of dollars
right right so he doesn't make like so
he's just a moment Playboy Wayne
Enterprises there's a division
r d thank you so much and they have the
money and they just he has a dude like Q
or whatever Morgan Freeman Morgan
Freeman yeah yeah Morgan Freeman yeah
what's his name I don't know yeah let's
call him Mr Mosley I like um
because I like he looks like I missed
her mostly I really loved the original
Batman animated series the one from like
the early 90s WB uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that the first few seasons of that I
thought were yeah because you like
things colorful
right and you like things to frolic wait
what don't you like about Batman what
have you I didn't say it didn't like it
I thought you said you know what I don't
like about Batman I'm gonna wait was
about the espresso thing the [__]
phone
I just wanted to go do the foam thing
and it became this I'm sorry you can't
express yourself
okay so here we go right let's go back
now okay okay so the Batman right so the
Riddler gives himself out right right
and now he's just at a diner yeah right
right he orders one a cappuccino am I
saying it right yeah
and he orders a cappuccino right and he
knows that the FBI and the FEDS I think
thousands of dudes are like gonna up he
because he wants he's he planned this to
get caught
but he's sitting there doing a
something on this right that and he
makes that it's too perfect
what's perfect that's that
question mark oh the design and then
because he's like this is where in the
Batman movie you couldn't suspend your
belief
I'm out I'm out wow I'm out I was out
after this
The Riddler and then you're like but the
foam it's just too perfect you know I
mean it'd be better if it was like kind
of like oh I think I know what that is
yeah but you know how stupid audiences
are I think I'm like I don't understand
what I'm looking at like they need to be
like that's right that's what it is okay
okay you should have done one upside
down one for the Latinos
[Laughter]
move on so um in the morning
s
so early in the mornings when you go in
your hotel you like to order
um espressos oh I mean lattes yeah
that's that's what the point was yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you like the foam and
you like the designs on the top yep yeah
yeah
um okay that's that's you
oh dirty
do you know that that really is me
there's nothing more gain anal about
wanting certain kind of lattes
remembering and that's just who I am
yeah yeah yeah that's you so um
he's a Starbucks guy
why oh you know what's funny I took they
opened up a Starbucks in Rome in Rome
Italy yeah
who's an Italian comedian he's great we
went there he's never been to Starbucks
so when we go inside he goes you know
what